estoy elección de grande de karate de
perú de la categoría entre 61 kilos
kumite
siempre ha sido mis sueños que mi
deporte sea olímpico ya lo es ahora lo
único que debe dar el 200% en el evento
abre las expectativas como entrenados
son súper altas de hecho queremos seguir
haciendo historia ya lo estamos haciendo
dejar en alto el perú y lo que sí
tenemos claro es que vamos a volver a
ser los mejores del mundo en las
olimpiadas
yo entreno toda la mañana lo que es
preparación física entre dos horas a
tres horas depende de cómo es el plan
que mi entrenador con el proveedor
físico lo van realizando porque estamos
entrando ahorita en fuerzas sé que
necesito sacar un poco más fuerza se
juntan y dice bueno alexandra necesita
tener empezar a sacar fuerza para llegar
a ser una potencia fuerte y por ende
mejora la velocidad
[Música]
despertó la música representa para mí es
un relajo estoy aquí en mi casa y pongo
música o veo conciertos de repente puede
ser mi secreto no escuchar música más
que toda la gente de mis categorías
están entrenando y ya están calentando
alexandra lo que hay que poner en sus
auriculares se sienta y ahí nos cierran
los ojos y empecé a escuchar música
el nivel que voy a llegar a toque 20 ya
es lo que va a ser mejor que en otros
eventos
la prevención es para tokio entonces ya
esto lo tenemos meses atrás
años atrás
y lo tenemos bien claro lo que queremos
lo que buscamos y eso está allí en tokio
esperándolos